this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author and host
of the ken coleman show
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
if ken coleman's in the house that means
you are more than free
to bring your career questions your
questions about
job hunts your questions about landing
in a position that you
have passion for as well as
get paid well for and all that kind of
stuff so ken's here to help and you
see you got a good opinion on that stuff
too dude i got an opinion about
everything i know
and i am an expert on my opinion yeah
but we get calls on the kick home show
about toxic culture what do i do i got a
a jerk boss but i've got i'm paying off
debt i mean dave gives a great
experience with that no stop it not true
you know but so many people are going
hey can i pay off debt and switch
jobs can i can i change careers while in
the baby steps so dave and i can take
that on
as well we can tag team yeah a lot of
leadership junk out there as well that
affects people's
hey is this the right place i'm doing
the right work maybe i'm in the wrong
place so
there's a lot of stuff we can take on
spousal hey my spouse is
is stuck how do i encourage the spouse
so a lot of questions we can answer
uh money and job related doing that
meaningful work
we're all here for you yeah the phone
number triple eight eight
two five five two two five and
kelly has stepped out in madison which
is actually uh ken's assistant producer
that's her phone screener so she
actually knows how
to uh screen calls for ken so she can
actually answer the questions as well
yeah she's heard them all kelly can
answer all my questions is that the
truth
and if you don't believe me ask her so
all right
genevieve is with us to start this hour
in los angeles hi genevieve how are you
i'm doing good i'm doing good so happy
to be on the call with you guys
you too what's up in your world all
right
so we have a duplex um we bought it
about
seven years ago and we owe about 287 on
it
um i guess you should start by saying
i'm on baby step two i have about 40 000
left to pay off in the combination of
student loans and
credit card debt that i refinanced and
we've been aggressively paying it for
the last two years about
60 000 has already been paid off and um
we were looking to refinance our duplex
for a lower rate and a lower payment and
our loan officer just told us you know
what
have you thought about refinancing
pulling the cash out and reinvesting it
so i'm wondering if that's a good idea
it has a positive cash flow right now
and
that's kind of where i'm at i'm like do
i continue paying off my debt
or go ahead and reinvest no well let me
just
tell you if you ask a loan officer if
you should borrow more money that's like
asking
a dog if it's hungry all right
and it would eat itself until it died
if you didn't take the food away from it
and that's a loan officer they will loan
you money from
from today on and they always have a
good idea on how to raise their
commission
yeah so no yeah no you're not trying to
get into debt darling you're trying to
get out remember
yeah yeah and it's funny because we come
from a family of entrepreneurs and
investors and and i'm just like i want
to be
zero um but of course you know it's
tempting temptation is like you know
can we reinvest you know later on well
the question you have to ask yourself is
what's the shortest distance between
where you are
and wealthy is it borrowing more money
on the duplex and investing that or
is it getting out of debt and the actual
data says
it's getting out of debt
okay that's the shortest distance
between where you are
and wealthy and so if we're going to get
out of debt because it's the shortest
distance between where you are and
wealthy then getting into more debt
would be oxymoronic wouldn't it
yes okay yeah so what's your household
income and how quick you're going to pay
off this 40k with your cash flow
oh within the year i like you it's
awesome i
like you so just refinance that
refinance that duplex put it on as short
a term as you can put it on
on as low interest rate as you can put
it on and let's get that duplex paid off
now too
boom just like that one more loan
officer smack silly
i've been doing this 30 years and it
never gets old what is the score dave
ramsey 1 million to 0 on that one
uh you know what dave seriously i want
to ask you a psychology question there
because
what happens is she's doing the right
thing she's working the baby steps
paid off 60 000 40 to go within the year
they're debt-free
living like nobody else and she calls
the loan officer they do what they do
not demonizing but they're doing what
they're doing i will and
i know you will and it changes the
narrative so we have to switch the
narrative back and go no
i called to save money which is going to
help me get out of debt faster because
if i'm saving money on
the current mortgage payment uh it means
more money towards
the debt snowball and that narrative
just gets all jumbled
in their minds yeah it is human nature
and it is really actually intelligent in
a way
to look for the easiest route
we want the easiest route right and you
really should why would you take the
hard route if there's an easy one i mean
it's intelligent
intelligent to do that yeah you want to
take the easiest route but the
in search of the easiest route we tend
to
it's all of us tend to look for a pill
if i could just take that get out of
that pill i'd be out of debt
i could take that lose weight pill i'd
lose weight if i could take that
uh make my marriage happy pill we don't
want to do the stuff
uh you know no discipline seems pleasant
at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
human nature is
to look for the easiest route and that
leads us if we're not careful
over the precipice into the get rich
quick mindset
into the there's a shortcut right
everybody knows about but me that's
right and i think i found it that's the
truth
there's not one yeah there's no shortcut
to any place it's worth going
and that's the trap dave the progress oh
progress is smart so the very thing
that's not smart
it's dumb to do that take on more debt
it feels smart because it's progress
it feels well it feels like it's a
shorter
yes it's a short term there quicker oh
that's an easier
route yeah and um because oh look i feel
better
all that debt's gone i don't think about
it and instead i gotta crunch and
run and grind through the rest of the
year but then when it's gone it's really
gone
because see here here's here's an
interesting fact about the math on this
you cannot borrow your way out of debt
that is true let that one sink in yeah
just get that'll get you there in a
minute if you keep digging you can't get
out of a hole while digging out the
bottom
and so you can move your debt
to your home your duplex your you can
move it around that's what debt
consolidation does it allows you to feel
like you did something
but the debt is still there it just has
a new name that's right
it you just moved it it's all you did so
please don't act like
you invented fire okay you didn't do
something that was really
you that's the but that's the that's why
i call it debt
consolidation here's here's how we know
that this is true
88 of people that take out a debt
consolidation loan
to end quotes air quotes pay off their
debt which it wasn't paid off it was
just moved
88 that's nine out of 10 times
end up not changing their habits and
running up new debt
over there so they move the credit cards
over onto the second mortgage
and now they run up new credit cards
because they don't change the habits 88
9 out of 10 times
but it felt like you were doing
something oh yeah very smart this is a
smart move i'm getting a lower interest
rate
our interest rates are we better off
with our interest rate it's all about
the interest rate it's not about the
fact that i can't freaking stop my
spending like i'm in congress
and so and that's not genevieve this is
just a thing
this is the day for this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help you get there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
ramsey to find out more
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host here today on the ramsey show
thank you for joining us the phone
number here triple eight
eight two five five two two five as we
talk about your careers your money your
life anything you wanna talk about
speaking of careers here at ramsey
solutions we are trying to do something
pretty radical we want to transform
so many lives that disruption
spreads like wildfire across our country
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan
where the majority people pay cash for
their cars where the credit card has
become the cigarette of the financial
world
where living and working in a job that
you
love in a career field that you love and
prospering is
normal instead of statistically
philosophically unusual at ramsey
solutions that's why we have a thousand
people at this company working together
to create digital products and all kinds
of goods and services
to help people transform their lives
with the goal of disrupting this toxic
culture and if you don't think that the
culture in america is toxic you haven't
come outside lately
if you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for many
software engineers
ruby on rails java c-sharp front-end
technologies
if you're a ux designer we need you seo
content marketing specialists
we'd love to talk with you digital
designers we're there baby
any just about anything we've got about
360 positions to fill this
year we are exploding here
we're just finishing up a new building
next door and that means there's
room for people it's that simple so find
out about all these opportunities at
daveramsey.com
click on the right hand side button
it says dave's hiring if you're a senior
level developer
how about this when you teach people and
mentor people and coach people to write
code they're writing code that changes
people's lives
not that's going into a black hole it
actually matters
oh and by the way we go home at six
o'clock we don't work you 80 hours a
week
we have this weird idea that you should
actually be a good dad and a good mom
and be home with your kids and that's
really weird if you're in the technology
world
because they try to kill people in the
technology world it's almost like first
year law students isn't it
they just churn through them yeah and
churn and burn baby
all right ashley's with us in sacramento
hi ashley what's up
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um so i just have a question so
my husband and i were we're debt-free we
luckily
were able to get through school without
any debt
and my husband just landed his first job
out of school and he's making some good
money so we
opened up with his 401k and then also
opened up a roth ira and we've
been contributing a little bit um but i
know you recommend
15 to go towards retirement but we're
also trying to
save for a down payment so i was
wondering do you still
recommend the 15 while we're trying to
save for that or
is it okay to do a little less or okay
how old are you guys
um i'm 21 and he's 24. okay
well first let's establish you've got
some time
there is not a rule that says you go to
hell if you don't buy a house by 25.
okay you're gonna be okay you're gonna
you got a little time to work on this
you don't have to panic
uh you're gonna be just fine and you've
done a really good job so far
very well done all right two things one
is we teach a process called the baby
steps
one is a thousand dollars saved you've
done that two is debt free you've done
that
three is a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses have
you got that
yes we do good excellent okay and what's
your household income
um so he's making sixty thousand months
little job searching
that's cool so what do you think you'll
be making when you land something
um probably around thirty okay so you
have roughly a hundred thousand dollar
income
90 to 100k right in there and you're
just beginning your career so it'll go
up that's excellent
okay now we teach after people are at
baby step three they have their
emergency fund and they're debt free if
they
are ready to buy a home at that point
then you would save up your down payment
if you want to put your retirement
savings on hold temporarily we call that
baby step
3b baby step 3 being the emergency fund
3b
be being saved for the down payment on
your home okay okay
and if you want to so if you want to sit
out of retirement for two years
or three years and pile up cash very
rapidly now the other thing i'm hearing
is i think i'm hearing you're not on a
written budget
and you guys need to get a detailed
written game plan
because uh you would have known exactly
what was going on you've got general
concepts and again you've done a really
good job but i want you to get in a
detailed written budget
jump on every dollar it's an app you can
download for free
and start to figure out how to put that
budget together or look at a free
uh trial at ramsey plus where you can
use the every dollar
premium budget version and get through
the classes as well
julie is with us julie is in nashville
hi julie how can we help
um yes i have a question so for
accreditation at my job
the mean salary for my position is about
12k more than i'm making
and i have about two years before i can
make the next level
and i just wondered if i you know
talking about her ken saying
don't go after a raise about how you can
develop and grow
and so if i go and ask her a growth plan
should i
mention like you know i i know that
because the tables are posted like i'm
less than this
that i'm at the current salary you know
at my current position
um i do know that i for my location i
make
more money in the area than you know
other
jobs in the area okay yeah so
i didn't quite understand that last part
because i think it's got to be industry
specific so if you're trying to industry
specifically right
it's industry specifically okay but what
you're saying is the median across the
nation you're about 12 000 lower but not
in your area
but not in your area no yeah so my area
for my area i'm actually higher okay but
for my
my specific company i'm actually 12k
less than what they post for my title
okay
okay well okay so that's great
information uh and so you're right
i want the rest of the audience to hear
this dave i don't like people going in
and asking for a raise it puts your
leader
in a very awkward position if there's
been no conversation there and so ramsey
solutions we've got a wonderful
wonderful
rhythm around this around growing and
that is we have
a very clear kra key results area it's
one page
for everybody including the
personalities and so there's
clear goals there's clear
boundaries for this is the work that i'm
responsible for these are the results
i'm responsible for and then we meet
every year an annual meeting of course
there's meetings all the time around
here with our leaders
but here's here's the deal i don't want
to ask for a reason when you sit down
and say hey i want to grow
and i i know that i need to grow my
skills
i'd like to know from you if we could
get together don't put them on the spot
and say hey i'd like to have a meeting
soon where we talk about a growth plan
that includes me
adding some skills that you think maybe
i need to add
strengthening some areas where i'm good
but i could be better to add more value
to the organization
and then you want to say hey as i want
to do those things i want to be measured
on that growth
and as a result i'd like to see how that
may lead to additional responsibilities
and more influence
in my position or in the company and and
when i'm growing professionally
then that leads to a natural
conversation of growing
my income and so that's how i like
people to
to bring the leader in let the leader
have some ownership and speak into
uh your growth and i think because
you're in a situation
where you're paid you could go in with
information
and say hey here's what the median is
and i've done some research on this but
i
i don't like bringing that into the
conversation until there's a growth plan
that's agreed upon because here's what i
know dave and a healthy organization
with healthy leadership
they will respond the right way and
they'll say sure we can do that
and if they don't have the built-in
systems that we have at ramsey solutions
this can develop that and healthy
leadership will accept that and figure
that out if they don't already do it and
then the conversation dave
is it okay off the back end of that
conversation to say
because i noticed that i'm 12 000 below
the posted amount and i want to know
what i need to do to be worthy
that's it you bring that up after you
say hey i want to grow and make myself
more valuable the company with your
measurement yeah and that's why
i do want them in that conversation to
recognize that she's being paid less
than their stated amount yes
absolutely that's a i would want to know
that as the leader but you do that in
the actual meeting that we described not
setting up the meeting off the back of
the conversation not in the actual
meeting you're not opening the
conversation with that it's
closing the conversation with that yep
that's it that's i got it
okay yeah because i would want to know
that as the leader so i could make the
adjustment because i would go oh crap i
didn't realize that that's exactly right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
i'm dave ramsey your host michael is
with us
michael's in boise idaho hey michael how
are you
i'm better than i deserve how yourself
better than i deserve sir how can i help
um i got a quick question for you my
wife and i are in baby steps four five
and six
and i've got some savings bonds that my
grandad gave me for my birthdays and
christmases growing up as a kid
they totaled about 900. so we're not
talking about a lot of money here but
i do want to honor my granddad with what
i do with this money so
i have a two-part question first would
be dave do you have a guiding principle
on how to honor financial gifts given by
family members
who pass away well i always just
it's a general concept i always just
think well when i do this is he going to
be in heaven smiling
that's good that's really good and so
you know it might be that he told you
this is for your college
and it didn't ever end up getting used
for college for whatever reason
and instead he hated debt and you used
it to pay off a credit card
well he'd be smiling even though it
wasn't the original intent because it
but it matches with who he
is or was right right
you know so my granny used to give us
savings bonds all times for our kids
college
and of course they don't pay squat and
so as soon as i could get a hold of as
soon as i could get a hold of them uh
and she she blessed her heart she
believed in savings bonds and she was
religious she gave those 50
100 200 for popper they're coming in for
the kids
and as soon as i could cash them out i
cashed them out and put them in a mutual
fund
and uh bless her heart i told her the
truth i did not lie to her she would say
how's those savings bonds doing i said
they're doing great granny
because they are they're now in a mutual
fund so they're actually freaking
producing something but i didn't give
her the details i just told her the
truth they're doing great now
because her intent was to help the kids
have some money for college and
her intent was uh what i did with them
i i didn't go uh buy a steak
at a steakhouse for myself
that would not have made her smile right
and then i would have had to lie to her
or
the truth and she'd been mad or whatever
but you know but but
the point is you know what's the right
thing to do and
you know that's my guiding principle on
honoring whether they're alive or dead
but certainly where there's inheritance
what it does it keeps you from doing
something childish
like if your grandpa leaves you a
hundred thousand dollars in exxon stock
and you go buy a used lamborghini well
that's dumber than a rock
yep you know and that ain't gonna make
him smile because he can't spell
lamborghini i can just tell you that so
you know i know i can't that's two of us
michael well i mean
that's the whole thing so the the point
is just because when you get an
inheritance you kind of have
oh it's like you said it's 900 it's not
a lot of money but put a couple zeros on
it's 90 grand now okay
and so if it's 90 grand then you know
what you have is you have a little bit
of that lotto moment like
game on baby road trip you know and you
start thinking about what you're going
to do with this money that's really
irresponsible and immature
yeah i got a thought here michael i'm
just gonna give you this and you take
this
um if it were me because of your
financial status
baby step four five and six you're
rocking it nine hundred dollars is not
going to make that big a difference
it's not like you it would take care of
a baby step or
excuse me a a debt in the debt snowball
i i would ask yourself or maybe talk to
your mom and dad
what if you knew him well what what did
he love what fired his soul up was there
a cause was there an activity that
that he really loved and if it were me i
i would do something really cool or
consider doing something really cool
with that 900
around that something because i heard in
your voice
you want to honor him and you're doing
such good with your finances 900 bucks
doesn't make a huge difference i love
you can use it
in your baby steps and keep on rolling
or you could do something cool here dave
that let's just say he was
he was into hunting or he he he was into
woodwork or something and you could
bless somebody maybe who's starting out
or
uh or or you know generosity moves
generosity
in the in the spirit of your grandfather
that he would smile from heaven on that
amen
eric is with us in fort lauderdale hey
erica what's up
hi dave hi ken uh first of all thank you
so much
dave you changed me in my husband's life
no you did i'm proud of you
oh thank you um so my husband and i um
we are our question is whether we keep
our house or not
we we actually are in ministry we live
overseas um right now in the caribbean
and and basically uh we are we have a
house in fort lauderdale
and we're fully supported by churches
so um but the thing with our house right
now is it
we're planning to stay where we are
maybe for the next five to nine years
we've come to that decision
so we have this house in fort lauderdale
and
it needs a new roof insurance isn't
paying for it so we can't go through
that
it's south florida so taxes are really
high and we're learning about all this
we didn't realize this with taxes and
everything
um and so we're just considering selling
it yes
um yes okay
today wow this thing's not a blessing
it's a curse
it's not bringing you peace yeah that's
true
it's not it's not adding to your life
can you make money on it
yeah they'll make money on it you can
make money on can't you when you sell it
yeah yeah yeah dave yeah yeah i just
wanted to confirm that i mean so i think
i put some money in the bank to ensure
that to ensure that your missionary
endeavor doesn't run up underfunded at
some point yeah
and you know all the missionaries keep
this is a problem as all the
missionaries tell us
and we just witnessed it don't tell your
house like this is the thing with
missionaries
they they don't have anything when they
go back so they're like don't sell your
house whatever you do so i think a big
part of us is like
if we sell it you know we don't want
that money that
well i i disagree with that sentiment
and i have told missionaries that for 30
years
that is a wrong statement you should
sell your house if you're going to be
gone five years you should sell your
house it take the proceeds
and take whatever you would have spent
on a house payment and
invest it in good mutual funds so that
you have a nice house fund
to buy a home when you come home um
yeah but the idea that you need to keep
your property and try to be a
long-distance landlord
while you're trying to serve jesus in
the caribbean that is just dadgum hard
that just adds pain to your life not
blessings yeah scarcity versus abundance
you're not going to be homeless when you
come back yeah you can especially
you need to have a plan to have a home
when you come back so that part
that's what's driving them to make the
statement of never sell your house
because they're afraid they're
not going to have the money to buy a
house because they've never saved
anything
so if you don't plan to have a home when
you come back
by investing then you then then you've
made a real mistake
but you need to plan by continuously
investing to be ready to return
let's run the numbers out on that dave
because i think it was great advice i
mean just a ballpark number let's say
they make a hundred grand on their house
or 150 and they put it in a mutual fund
she said they're going to be there five
to nine years
she puts in a good mutual fund that
becomes that housing fund if all their
other expenses on the mission field are
covered
that becomes a sizeable down payment
it'll it'll double yeah it'll double in
about seven years
that's the narrative again that's not
happening yeah but if you take that
money
and spend it to live on the mission
field and you have
zero money and zero house and you come
off yeah
that's the fear that has created this
thing oh never sell your house when you
go on this field
now if you're going to mission field for
six months that's a different thing
these people are gonna be gone five
seven years ten years whatever
so that's a different that changes the
equation as well kimberly
is in san bernardino california but
we're going to come to her
after this commercial break i just
looked up and saw the
uh i saw the clock creeping up on us
homeowners insurance can be one of those
set it and forget it kind of things when
you first bought your home you may have
just gone with whatever coverage the
lender had or the
realtor suggested or whatever you need
to get your insurance
requoted go to one of our endorsed local
provider insurance agents they are
independent brokers they will shop among
several different companies
and get you the best possible price on
your home or
auto or both the average person coming
in
uh to this it saves about 700 a year
and the quote to get how much it cost to
get a quote nothing it's free
so text the word home to 33
789 you need to continuously check on
your insurances to make sure you're not
being
overcharged one thing she was just
talking about was the cost of insurance
in south florida it's
very real so text home
to 33 789 home to 33789
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
time
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today you can hear the ken
coleman show
on sirius xm as a podcast we're at about
75 radio stations around america so be
sure you tune in
he speaks every day to people all over
america about how to get
and keep the best career path
that puts you into what he calls your
sweet spot living your passion kimberly
is with us in san bernardino california
hi kimberly how are you
good hi dave i had a question um
me and my husband are kind of debating
um
our question is should my husband take a
new job
and depending on the retirement we don't
know a lot about retirement so we don't
know the questions that we should ask
he currently has a job where he has a
tier one and tier two that he pays him
to he works for the railroad
so the new job from what we know
that he was offered does not offer
retirement but they match six percent i
don't know
what questions to ask to make a wife's
choice okay
um well i mean if if they're if they
have a 401k that they match in six
percent that sounds like a fairly
normal company type position
versus the railroad which has a very
unusual
retirement system okay okay so what does
your husband make at the railroad
he you want to know hourly no annually
okay i have the paper in front of me so
annually
um i don't okay so annually it shows i
don't think it has one here
so i'm thinking around what does he
bring what's he bring home a month
or a week or whatever okay so he gets
paid every two weeks about
twenty one hundred dollars one thousand
after ten
yes twenty one hundred dollars and so
forty two hundred dollars a month
so 48 000 a year and so he's making
about 60
65 000 depending on what's coming out of
his chat okay
correct okay now what's the new job pay
25 an hour so whatever that is times 80
times okay i don't know what that is
but um 50 grand okay thank you a guy in
the lobby just helped me all right
so uh you're gonna make about the same
or a little bit more
at the new job okay right okay now the
question here though is
how old is he my husband's 30.
okay so when he's 60 old like me
what's he going to be glad he spent the
last 30 years doing
which one of these what i
think saving for retirement paying off
no no no no
no that wasn't what i was talking about
can this is yours
yeah so here's the thing we've got the
numbers right
he's making 60 to 65 now on the railroad
this new job is going to pay him about
50.
so it's a pay cut yeah if we got those
numbers right
so that's the first issue but what dave
was asking is why does this guy want
this job why does your husband want the
job does he want it because he loves the
work and it's it's work that matters to
him in long term he hates the railroad
yeah why is he what the
what's the what's the reason for the new
job with the railroad he can't go up
anymore so that's the top okay good so
he's captain
good job yes correct so with the new job
he does start off at 25 but after three
to six months he goes back to 32.
there we go now we're moving the right
direction so this is a temporary pay cut
for the opportunity to advance not just
financially but also professional
what would he be doing at the new job um
so far what i know it's called the
operator d
so it's um borax i don't know if you
guys ever heard of borax it's called
boron rio tinto
so they um it's a mine and they do
minerals so
he would be packaging shipping out
minerals
everything to do with uh it's not
under the ground line it's above the
ground it has to do with the minerals
they put them in electronics
when he talks to you when he talks to
you about it what do you think his
excitement level is
exciting what do you think his
excitement level is when you hear him
talk to you about this new job on a
scale of one to ten one
no excitement ten he's throwing a party
what's his excitement level when he
talks to you about this new job
ten then it's a no-brainer so you guys
need to plan for the short term
retirement
you take the 401k you get out of debt
you do your baby steps
maybe step three is in place of three to
six months of expenses you're debt-free
and then you put 15 of your income away
for retirement and you will retire
wealthy
15 you need to put 15
of your income away for retirement and
they're going to match another six
and so you're going to retire wealthy if
you do that
okay so you're fine you're not you're
not you are not
going to retire and have to eat alpo
that's right
okay good to know here's here's the
other thing never
take a job ever ever just for the money
never take a job ever because of the
freaking benefits package
that's true always take a job because it
has a bright
future and makes you smile doing the
work
yes this is the way you make a decision
on a job
not based on the freaking 401k match
that's exactly right now
let's go back into our baby steps dave
let's walk let's walk
other people through this because this
call we get this a lot on the ken
coleman show i know a lot of people
listening watching right now
are feeling this too so this is a
temporary pay cut okay
so in three to six months he's going to
go from 25 an hour
to around 32 an hour so they need to get
back into their budget and go okay
we have to plan for a temporary
pay cut but it's temporary so we got to
adjust the budget
we plan for this and we absorb this your
thoughts on that yeah absolutely
absolutely don't act like it's not
happening yeah because they only end up
you know i ran up five thousand dollars
in credit card debt yeah we took a pay
cut
you know that's that's dumber than a
rock don't do that so you got to plan
it's going to happen it's going to
happen so plan on the
drop in pay make sure you're going to br
lower your lifestyle to fit that
and then you can then you can begin your
investing process later but
yeah railroad retirement is incredible
it is
not so incredible that you should keep a
job making
absolute ceiling on your ability to
progress
and keep a job that you don't like doing
yeah this is important to point out
that you know when it's time to consider
moving on when you
have been told and it's been made
obvious to you that you've hit your lid
now you've got to sit back and go okay
am i okay with this lid because dave you
know this we as humans are creatures of
progress it's just
wired into us by our creator we want to
make progress we want to grow
some people have gone so far as to say
if you're not growing if you're not
learning you're dying
now you there are some jobs where you go
hey this is it
and i'm good here and this is it but for
those of you who want more
in your work and you're in an
environment where because of the
organization or the leadership
there is an artificial lid on you you're
not moving up
it's time to start thinking about moving
on
absolutely that'll wear on you jeff is
in raleigh north carolina hi jeff what's
up
i'm doing well how about you guys good
how can we help
so i'm curious i have 61 000 in a
ira rollover account from previous work
history i'm curious if i should roll
that
into a roth ira i'm in baby step
two no because you're gonna
you're gonna create twelve thousand
dollars worth of taxes to add to your
baby step two
so i am um hear me out for a second
so i was 17 five on my truck
i have fifteen five in savings and i'm
getting
ten thousand dollars back uh in taxes
this year
so that's gonna wipe out my debt we'll
be on baby steps three
good and you still don't have you still
don't have an extra fifteen thousand
dollars to pay the taxes
uh so my numbers if i moved half of it i
would get 27 hours
let's just stop okay i would not do this
okay i would i it's an old 401k is that
what you said
yes i would roll it to a traditional ira
in good mutual funds
later on in your wealth building i would
convert it to a roth
in a few years after you get the house
paid off and do some other things and
you've got some extra cash laying around
but when you throw 15 000 or whatever
at this you know a fourth of it's going
to be taxes roughly
at this account because you're rolling
it to a roth
then that's money you could have used to
build your emergency fund
build your kids college fund get the
house paid off and some things you
should do before
you send the government money and so i
instead would just
move it to a traditional ira and let it
sit there and grow in some good mutual
funds
and convert it to a roth later
you need the fifteen thousand dollars
that you would be spending on taxes to
do things that are more important than
this becoming a roth today
it's a matter of priorities you do what
you want but that's what you asked
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman ramsey personality
and career expert host of the ken
coleman show
author of the number one best-selling
book the proximity principle
is my co-host today so you've got
questions about career about jobs
well you can mix those in with the
questions where we talk about life and
money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five
five two two five and is with us in
orlando florida hi ann
welcome to the ramsay show hello thank
you so much for taking my call
sure what's up um well i'm a widow
and i just am really concerned about my
debt my future
on a positive i just received a ten
thousand dollar check in the mail
on the opposite end of my primary
mortgage was just sold to a lender that
i'm not comfortable with i need a new
roof and i have a heloc
so i'm considering refinancing all of
that together
um it would also be a much significant
um interest rate
and then for the and then taking that
ten thousand dollar check and throwing
that at the credit card
and i have a bonus check next month that
i think will take care of the one other
debt that i have
is that a good plan to get me set up so
that i can retire
well in the future how old are you i'm
53
okay and what do you make about 63 a
year
okay when's your husband pass um he
passed five years ago
i'm sorry um sounds like you are really
on top of things
proud of you very well done i like mine
i have my moments
i like everything in your plan except
borrowing to do the roof
okay so your plan is really good you
need to get rid of that heloc and that
higher interest rate mortgage by
refinancing and get a cheaper rate i
love that part of the plan
that's really good the ten thousand
dollars towards the credit cards makes a
lot of sense is the roof leaking
it is not um but locally a lot of the
insurance companies are
requiring that people re-roof their
homes and the roof on my house
is probably about 20 years old so it's
getting about time that it's going to
need to be done
okay do you have a bed on it i have
people coming out next week to give me
bids
okay how big a house is it
um it's uh 20 it's 2300 square foot but
i also have a 600 square foot lanai
and that just has a different type of
roof yeah is it asphalt shingle roof
yes it is okay all right cool you make
63 and you have
how much credit card debt there are 17
on the card
okay and that's your only debt other
than your home
um i have one other debt i still have
twelve hundred dollars left on the
monument
um for our gravesite and anticipating
being able to pay that off next month
with my with a bonus check
okay how much is your bonus trick gumby
um it varies um but
it generally it should be about a net of
thirteen hundred dollars
okay all right so we've got counting the
ten thousand we've got
eleven thousand three hundred dollars we
got a twelve hundred dollar bill and a
17 000
bill right yes okay
so let's get in attack mode knock the
little bill out and let's get those
credit cards knocked out make sure
they're cut up
finish paying off that debt build your
emergency fund and then build you a roof
fund
and refinance your first and your second
together i i don't want you going into
debt further on this house because part
of your retirement plan is getting this
house paid off
um yes it is i have a whole lot of
equity in the house and
i should still be able to get the house
paid off in 15 years
yeah well you yeah yeah you're going to
because you're not going to borrow for
the roof
yeah so yeah we're going to put this on
a 15 year
and you're going to be done with it
sooner than that and you're going to
save up and pay cash for this roof and
you're going to be able to make
all of that work because you're going to
lay out a detailed plan
and um the good news about you is you
are
really paying attention i'm very proud
of you
there's not anything happening on
accident here you've spent a lot of time
thinking about this
and it led you to really good
conclusions except for that one detail
and so you know you really have done you
know you did
really smart when you came on the air
but all everything you're going doing is
in the right direction
joseph's in kansas city hi joseph what's
up
good afternoon gentlemen yes sir honor
to be talking with uh with you and
ken on the show today this is more of a
mindset question
more than do we have the funds okay i
have actually been unemployed for 10
months my wife has been working
i do collect i do collect
basically we've saved money aside to
build a home and
uh we're having a we've been saving for
over 20 years
to actually buy or build a newer home
and
now it's come time i've i inherited
property three years ago
and it was actually burned down b's
property but
beautiful piece of land and you know we
currently own the whole
our home now we have absolutely no debt
live an old
dave ramsey way you know our newest cars
from 1999
that we keep it running so
you know we're looking for for actually
some guidance beyond family
because everyone else in the family says
live on debt we do not believe in that
at all we have absolutely no debt
so regarding this it's more of a mindset
question
we we've been saving for 20 years we can
actually we have the cash to build the
home but we're just having such a hard
time
of actually signing that contract to go
ahead and begin the build
why because it's been over 20 years
of saving living very frugal way below
our means
which would make me want to sign that
contract and get this crap done
that's a good point dave and yeah you
know uh
both of us we've never made more than 20
bucks an hour
uh the house bill itself is going to be
about 240 000
how much is inside uh we currently have
416 000 cash in retirement we have 308
000.
okay so um what is it that's scaring you
it's the fact of
i just have not ever made a whole lot of
income and it's going to take a long
time to replace
that 230 240 000 that we're going to be
spending so
primarily it's a matter of finding
another position
i'm actually starting my own investment
advisory firm i've been financial
coaching no fee for years
and it's something that i love to do but
i'm still looking for employment
and uh well if you want to wait until
you get employment and that gives you
the sense of stability to do this that
would not be illogical
yeah but joseph here's the deal you got
plenty of money
but if if if that's the last emotional
hurdle
hurdle uh that says you know i really
want to have a job for a break ground on
this thing
there's nothing that says you have to
start today
right and dave i gotta address this
joseph you when dave asked you point
blank what the fear is
it's it's i've saved so much money over
so
long a period of time and once i spend
it on this house
it's gone and it's not let's say that 10
15 years from now you want to sell that
house that's going to appreciate you
paid cash for it if i'm understanding
that right that money's coming back and
then some
yeah and the home you're that is perfect
yeah yeah and the home you're in is paid
for and it turns into a really nice
rental property i suppose
uh yes sir it's actually it's this
little two-bedroom home
uh do it
you're ready to go if you want to wait
till you get a job that's fine
but you're ready to go there's nothing
financially out of place here it's just
hard
you're right it's hard to turn loose so
it took you a long time to get here
and you kind of like that pile of money
being there yeah and
that's a normal human reaction so but
it's
you did it you you this is what you did
it for now enjoy the fruits of your hard
work and discipline
[Music]
you know healthcare has gotten to be
ridiculous
it puts people um you know on the brink
and so it would have put us on the brink
had we not had
chm chm saved our life same doctor
financial life
christian healthcare ministries or chm
is not health insurance
but it is a budget friendly option and
the original health cost sharing
ministry for christians
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple h
five two two five amelia is in boston
hi amelia how are you hi dave hi ken i'm
well thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um so i'm calling in
today to get some guidance
on getting on the same page with money
as my grandmother
actually she has given me a very
generous gift
and put it in a trust for me of a
hundred thousand dollars earmarked for
tuition and for a purchase of my first
home when the time
comes so we've taken chunks out of that
over the years
for tuition and there's about 75 000
left
i personally outside of that i'm just
about to finish baby step three so i'm
looking to purchase my first home in the
next
one to three years now the question here
that's causing some
uh contention and disagreement is that
that money is all invested in the market
mostly in
index funds right now and with me
wanting to use it in the relatively
short term
my position is that we should take it
out and have it in cash well my
grandmother's position
is you know it's done well it's earned
great returns over the last several
years
why would we not want to continue that
so i'm working on guidance as to
how to have that conversation um and do
what i believe is the right thing with
this money while
you know still being extremely grateful
for the gift
she gave you the money and she put it in
trust and she's managing the trust
correct she's a bit of a control freak
i i think with money it's mainly a
position of experience you know i'm
22 she's 74 so
she's got a lifetime of experience and
it does seem to me a bit controlling you
know i'm
a natural saver been financially
responsible for my whole life
you're in control and the money was
given to you by a house and you can't
take it out and buy a house with it
right i don't understand
yeah uh i mean that's that's the point
that i'm stuck at is
how to have that conversation um so are
you when are you gonna buy a house
um probably in two or three years
why two or three years uh because i'm
not sure that i want to stay in this
area
long term so uh you know i'm waiting to
get a little confidence there before i
make the financial commitment to a house
okay well this is more of an issue of uh
you know puppet master than it is actual
financial advice
right yeah and so that you know you just
got to decide which hill you want to die
on um as far as the you know her advice
goes it's not the end of the world okay
let's say that those
index funds went down 10
during that three years which would be
one of the worst three-year periods in
the stock market's history
sure then you would have lost seven
thousand dollars
right yeah it's it's not end of the
world either way yeah and and so
and if it goes up ten percent during
that time you would have made seven
thousand dollars
so you know you you're
fear of this money not of this money
being in the market
is not substance shouldn't be
substantial because the actual dollar
figures aren't going to be substantial
her wanting to take advantage of the
market is almost laughable
because it's also going to be about
seven thousand dollars
right it's a philosophical thing
you know is really all it comes down to
so
you know it and that reveals
that you guys are both being drama
queens about this
yeah but that's fair to say um yeah it's
you know it's not a big deal either way
but it's difficult to have the
conversation yeah it's just like
it's a control conversation right it's a
puppet master conversation and
you know so like i don't know if this
woman is actually going to release this
money when you're ready to buy a house i
can't tell
yeah i'm sometimes worried about that um
because she's actually taken out the the
growth that's already come onto the
account over time
so yeah yeah oh she took it out and used
it herself yeah
wow yes which i mean the original
balance is still there so that was her
call but
wow yeah that was not something i was
about to say
this is a little strange so here's what
i'm gonna do i'm just go about the
business of building up your own down
payment
and then if that money's there and she
wants to give it to you fine if not just
tell her to keep it
yeah absolutely that's fair enough
that's pretty much the plan
uh either way yeah because i i don't
think you're gonna win this argument
okay
she because her the problem with her
actually letting you buy a house with a
75
000 is that's the last conversation she
has where she gets to tell you what to
do
and she really likes telling you what to
do
so i okay so i got to ask you this i'm
surprised at your answer
i was a little surprised is it great i
mean it's dead on but i thought
don't you just die on that hill with
grandma you told me this is what it was
for
i'm not going to fight with you and ruin
our relationship but that's it
yeah i mean because listen you can hear
what's happening with this lady
and there is no winning the argument
with this woman 100 agree
okay so why have the argument because
you're not going to win it right you're
either going to sever the relationship
over seven thousand dollars and the
money's not the thing
it's the control mm-hmm and um so
and then the other side of that is if
i'm making a gift if i'm the grandma
okay i've often said on here you're
gonna get my money you're gonna get my
instruction
okay but i have never given someone a
gift
and then managed it right
that's not a gift yeah that's that's
controlling so that's you know but i i
would say
i'm not going to give you this gift if
you're not doing these things
but once it's given you need to take
your hand off of it i agree
and uh you're saying don't even try to
have the conversation and go hey listen
i don't want to fight i don't want this
to be good
grandma i love you and thank you for the
money and i hope it's there if you still
want to do it when we get ready to buy a
house that'll be fine because we're
going to go ahead and start building up
our own down payment
i know you'll be proud of us when we did
that i love you thank you and just keep
moving
because what it does just takes all of
her power away and she really is a lot
about power
that's true what happens when gra if
grandma dies before this
i suspect the trust has terms that leave
it too
beneficiary of the truth amelia okay
that okay yeah
that's good i needed to process through
that because sometimes it's like
principal let's have the conversation
and i think you're right now as i
process what you said it's like i'm
channeling my inner john d'alone
just tell them you love them and keep
going i think you're right i was
wondering though i was like okay trying
to be nicer deloney's
inspired me to be nicer he's very nice
he is a nice very in touch with his
feelings and ours
he's in touch with everyone's feelings
he really is he really is that's good
and he has a lot of feelings
yes he's not even here to defend himself
we're ragging on him
no he's awesome man he's he's great i
love it
regina is in nashville hi regina how are
you
fine dave hi uh thanks for having me on
the show hello
uh ken also how are you guys doing today
great how can we help you we're short on
time go straight to it
okay straight to it um all right i'm
unemployed my husband just got a job
about three weeks ago we moved from uh
california to the murfreesboro area
in october i'm having a heck of a time
finding a job we owe a ton in taxes
and our finances are a mess what did you
used to do
uh well my last position i was an office
assistant i've basically been
in office for about the last 20 years
my goal is to become a loan signing
agent within the next couple of
months uh so i'm looking for you know
something to tide me over until
that can be enough of an income so that
i can do that
well then here's what you do so regina
let me let me encourage this is a really
good job market in tennessee
and certainly in the greater nashville
area and you need to be just getting a
job or
two right now you've got an income
problem and so you can drive
you can deliver pizza you can show up
and work at a grocery store you can work
in a warehouse don't just limit yourself
to office management positions when
that's going to be a short term play it
seems like for you anyway right now
this is urgency and so we're going to go
get a job two job three jobs
just go get a job get stable
and then get back up on the horse
towards that purposeful plan
do anything yes so that you can do
anything later that's right
work like a crazy person and yeah
there's positions out there
lots of them in the murfreesboro area
murphy's brother's booming
booming but you need to broaden your
focus to almost
anything instead of so narrow so you get
landed in get the wolf away from the
door
because you got this wolf howling
outside that's driving you crazy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five jonathan and rachel are in
bowling green kentucky
says on my screen you guys are ready to
do a debt-free scream what's up
hey how are you great how much debt have
you guys paid off
we've paid off a hundred and two
thousand dollars in two years so 24
months
way to go and your range of income
during that time
so we started at about um 75 000
um by the time we were done we were we
were around about 115 000 and now we're
back down to about 70 000 but that'll be
going up soon we hope
good good deal so what do you guys do
for a living
um i'm a dental hygienist and i work for
ups
very but while we were paying off our
debt um
i was a dental hygienist but me and
jonathan we both worked at a
um at a restaurant together he was the
kitchen manager and i
was a waitress which i've done for
several years and we worked
countless hours between the two of us we
usually worked about 60 to 80 hours a
week so it was
how old are you guys um we're both 29.
very good and how long you've been
married oh this year will be eight years
we've been married
yeah so what happened two years ago that
lit you up you got on fire um
well it's funny i i was scrolling
through
facebook one day and we watched uh i
watched a youtube video of someone doing
their debt free scream and
i just remember thinking there's no way
we could ever do this
but i went ahead and bought your book
and it literally took me a whole year
before i picked it up and read it
it makes a great coaster on a coffee
table
it actually was and so i read the book
and the next day i came to jonathan and
i was like
listen i think this is what we need to
do and first he was like okay we
you know we can do it and then you know
it was hard at first and then one day i
came to him i was like listen we cannot
be working in restaurants for the rest
of our lives
not what we want to do and he was like
okay we'll buckle down and we did
so and that was two years ago that you
went crazy
it was two years ago that we went crazy
yep we remember every moment
yeah and you did 50 000 a year for two
years that's impressive
i mean you've been on beans and rice
rice and beans for sure
we sure did um there was many many times
we worked
seven days a week for the most part um
you know with jonathan he would get up
some days at um
6 a.m to go to work and we wouldn't
leave till 1 a.m uh for the restaurant
so
it was it was it was rough yeah and it's
over
it's over will you ever go back in debt
oh never again never again what kind of
debt was this
um it was several things we had student
loans mostly
and then cars and credit cards not a
whole lot of credit card debt though
and we had a little bit of medical debt
i think mostly it was um
our student loans and car alone so we
had a lease at the time which was
very dumb yeah wow i'm so proud of you
guys
well done thank you you are not afraid
of hard work
no and when you get absolutely not and
you're not afraid to work together and
these are very important things so what
do you tell people the key to getting
out of debt is because you did it
honestly it's just staying focused it it
really
i don't know i tell people it really
wasn't that hard once we put our minds
to it you know we we worked a little bit
more but we were already working so much
that it just
you know it kind of after a while it
came natural it was actually kind of fun
you know every month we'd just pay off
i mean more and more would go towards
the snowball and it was just it was
it was kind of fun wow well done well i
want to ask a question to both of you
because
this is this is something that i think
people need to catch
the fun part was the momentum each month
but there have got to be times when
you're working that kind of schedule
where you go
i know why we're working this hard i
don't ever want to have to work this
hard again
am i right you are absolutely right
jonathan's been lucky um going from
working 80 hours a week to
until he starts in his full-time
position at his job he's down to 20
hours a week and this is
everything he's ever dreamed of with the
work last
well i'm hoping you've taken a few naps
jonathan because you've earned
every day all good okay that's good to
know that's good
that's so great well done you guys who
were your biggest cheerleaders other
than the two of you
oh gosh definitely my mom for sure um
your parents yeah parents both of our
parents
have been really supportive through the
whole process we we really didn't have
you know i know a lot of people that go
through the debt-free journey they have
some naysayers we really didn't we had
everybody was so proud of us on board
with it so that helped so much my mom
and dad i mean
my dad would would text me or message me
every so often how much longer how much
longer i'm like we're getting there
we're working on it
i'd love to ask both of you how is your
relationship grown
when you've come together so intensely
on such a big goal and work so hard how
is your relationship your marriage
growing
i'd say it's definitely grown a lot
closer we've always you know had a great
relationship but
it's just a lot of give and take and a
lot of working together and this
has definitely helped help to strengthen
that i feel like i mean i think
it's helped us a lot because we've been
able to
we knew we were putting in an equal
effort you know
nobody we didn't give up on each other
we didn't you know as many times as we
wanted to say okay well let's go buy
this it's like no i mean if
if you don't get something then i'm not
going to get something so i think that
really really helped you know it helped
strengthen our relationship it helped us
keep us motivated so
what are you dreaming about they're
hearing that people are hearing this
story
they're watching this on youtube what
are you dreaming about now that you're
on the other side of this
as a couple um well we eventually want
to have kids so
that'll be you know we wanted to kind of
get out of debt to do that but
our most um reachable dream right now we
need to fix our shower so that's what
we're saving for now that's our dream
all right we'll take the little dreams
that's good that's good that's a good
first step
well done you guys very well done
your impressive young rock stars yeah
you got a bright future ahead of you you
know how to work together and you know
how to work
and uh and you know how to execute and
lay out a plan and execute on it you can
do that with any part of your life now
and you'll be able to do this for the
rest of your lives
absolutely very well done excellent
excellent work new grooves
are in your brain you are ready to rock
we got a copy of chris hogan's book for
you
everyday millionaires that is the next
chapter for you
and uh let's count it down i love it 102
000 paid off in two years making 75 to
115
a lot of work jonathan and rachel
bowling green kentucky count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
all right three two one we're down three
thank you well done you guys we're so
proud of you
excellent you know we had
some uh friends over for dinner the
other night a couple
two couples and we were telling old
stories from when we were that age
because that's the age we were when we
were bankrupt and uh
the guys like one of the one of the men
sitting there was
quizzing sharon he was doing the
interview routine right and uh getting
her side of the story
yeah because everybody everybody here is
my side of the story and sharon syrian's
great
people don't realize how fun she is when
she answers questions she's like
oh is the yellow pad and he said what do
you mean she said
well when we we make a we every night we
sat down with this stupid yellow pad
and wrote out a plan of what we were
going to do
this week next week and what we're going
to do 10 years from now
and she said we kept writing that yellow
pad and we kept writing that yellow pad
and we were you know the way we got
through bankruptcy
and the way we rebuilt our lives was
with a freaking plan and doing it
together
and it's a yellow pad and you know she
can see it in her head and i could see
sit i
remember that little oak table we're
sitting that little oak pedestal table
and we're sitting there with that yellow
pad going okay next things fix the
shower that's what made me think of it
yeah you know it's stuff like that the
first thing you know you know before you
start talking about
being a millionaire you fix the shower
it's the truth i thought it was a great
answer because that's the show's the
sacrifice
yeah they literally rice and beans
working themselves
no this is awesome look great great
couple because that's exactly what we
did we had
you know we had to fix the roof we had
to fix the heat in there dadgum air
conditioner was out you and i talked
about this a lot how good is that shower
gonna feel
it not because it's working yeah but
because of how hard you but if you went
down to home depot and put it on home
depot card
oh it would spit acid on you it's the
truth be like
shards of glass it'll never work
oh my goodness oh this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today as we talk to you about
your life and your money the phone
number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five scottie
is with us in west
palm beach hey scotty how are you i'm
great
dave and uh ken both of you thanks for
taking uh my call here and helping me
out sure how can we help
i'm a new sole proprietor and i set up
my
business checking and savings account
good but um
the bank named both of them as my dba
and i was under the impression from you
that it should have like
you know xyz corp tax savings account or
something to that
uh effect oh no no it doesn't have to be
named to that by the bank you just gotta
nickname it that on the file
oh okay because i didn't want you know
the irs to say well you have a checking
name for you and you have a savings name
no no the irs
the irs never sees any of that all we're
trying to do is make sure you set aside
money
out of your profits for taxes so you can
pay your quarterly estimates
and you just need a savings account to
do that and by that i mean a separate
savings account that you're not saving
for something else in and so you
accidentally spend your tax money when
you buy the something else
right and that's what i've done yeah
they're totally separate so then the
next the last question is
after i take that 25 out since i'm just
a sole proprietor what's the best way to
pay myself well just off the the
business the
the debit card or or do i really need to
set up
with a payroll company no you don't need
a payroll company you just write a check
out of your account
so you're you're a startup one-man show
right
yeah yes sir okay what kind of business
are you doing what are you doing
i'm starting a small messenger of
courier service
okay cool so you get some money in and
you throw it into the checking account
when you get ready to bring some money
out of that checking account
home you set 25 of that
amount over into that savings and the
other 75 percent comes out in
just a personal check written to you
okay out of my business account yeah
yeah so you take your business account
there's a thousand dollars in there
that you want to bring some home out of
that business account and pay some bills
or eat and some stuff like that
then you would write a 250 check in to
save and move it over to that savings
account you'd write a 750
check and take it home
does it strictly have to be a check it
couldn't be it just it could be anything
but if you you know however you're going
to do it i mean if you
how are you going to transfer you could
just do a transfer if it's inside
you know on your website but just always
keep that 75-25 rule going
because in effect you are withholding
like your employer withholds on you
they hold money out for taxes and that's
what we're doing with that 25
going over into savings right and pay
that quick and then that becomes my
quarterly
exactly and that becomes and that
becomes the equivalent of a
payroll company doing withholding that's
why you don't need a payroll company at
this stage
fantastic i wouldn't screw with a
payroll company until you have employees
got it and then then it's worth it using
one to not have to mess with
the irs calculations for all the
employees which will drive you freaking
bananas
that's another story though yeah that's
thank goodness very well
you have listened to some of the entree
leadership materials very carefully
scotty and you've done a great job with
that
so ken uh the reason we've instructed
people to do what scotty's doing that
are opening
solopreneur things is uh
the number one cause of small business
failure especially a solopreneur
crashing
is cash flow problems cash flow problems
mean you don't have any money
why don't you have any money because you
didn't pay your taxes when you get
behind with the irs
or you go into a bunch of debt yeah and
so what we've instructed here is
this is a situation we didn't get into
this part of the conversation but
if this is a side hustle for a while you
know
if that's the situation and you have a
day job then i would just keep
loading up that bank account and and
until it can until you're paying
yourself something that you really can
use
uh just get that company healthy in his
situation where it
may feel like he's doing this full-time
uh and giving it a go
uh having that tax and pulling that
aside and being disciplined there
and that's going to help you
tremendously as you learn the ropes of
this because the first time you start a
company you realize there are tax
benefits
get yourself a great ramsey tax advisory
and get somebody really knows what
they're doing
to make sure that you're protecting
yourself because people don't realize
when they work for a regular company
where people pull all this out they just
don't think about it they see the number
anything that's a 1099. yeah i mean if
you're if you're running
uh ubereats yes same thing and they're
not holding taxes out on you you better
pull it aside you're gonna you know you
run ten thousand dollars up you're gonna
get a two thousand five hundred dollar
extra tax bill in the year and you've
got no money for that
that's going to bite you in the butt
yeah and that's what happens in a small
business solopreneur startup like that
that's right you can get behind on those
taxes because you act like they're not
there and live off of all the money
that's right and that's a bad plan yeah
and don't pay yourself
if you don't have i just i get this call
a lot of the ken coleman show just want
to point out
if you don't have to pay yourself right
now and you can live off that day job
do it yeah stack some money up in that
side hustle yeah and just let it sit
there or
pull it all out and throw it on your
debt if that's what you're doing if
you're in the debt snowball absolutely
put every nickel towards you
after taxes archely is with us hey
archely how are you
hi i'm very well thank you for taking my
call good pronounce your name for me i
destroyed it
it's arisely hey aricelli okay thank you
it was just the sea that was pretty good
i messed it up okay but it's somebody's
name it's important
no no i've i've gotten aerosol and
so you're close enough that's great well
i didn't do that
yeah all right how can we help
i have a predicament i'm in the middle
of a divorce
um i get to keep the house my girls are
staying with me
um one's nineteen the other one is
seventeen um
there's no alimony you try to support
anything into the equation
the house is paid in full and i'm
even going to pay him out two hundred
thousand
two hundred thousand dollars so my
question is
whether i take out a loan to pay him
that amount or um my attorney indicated
i could take a
penalty free that money from my 401k i
don't know what to do
which option would be better lose the
interest on my
401k by doing that or
have this other language without the
uncertainty of me now being had a
household
and having your income all the bails and
everything
um when how about 120
okay well i i hate how you got here
i hate how you got here but if you call
me up and said i have a 200 000 mortgage
on a 15-year fixed rate and i make 120
000
a year and i got two teenagers i
wouldn't be panicked hearing that
but i don't i don't like how we got here
obviously you don't either it's been
painful
exactly i'm just you know i've always
had the cushion of
having him as a backup um but me now
being this whole hit a household
yeah how old are you debt free would
give me 50.
okay so i mean if you take out a 15-year
mortgage of 65 the house is paid for or
sooner if you pay it off early right
yeah and as the kids grow and move out
you know you're going to have more
margin and room in your budget to throw
serious money at this house and get it
paid off early
so yeah i think you take out a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage
okay and don't listen to your attorney
financial advice she's not very smart
no it was just because my i don't you
know coming into having all this
obligation now on me and the
responsibility um
i wasn't if you told me you made 70 000
i'd be telling you to sell the house you
understand that
okay yeah yeah definitely afford to live
there
because of this horrible situation
you've gone through i'm so sorry
so right thank you no fun at all how
long were you married
22 years how you doing
hanging in there sounds like it yeah
here's what we're gonna do i want you to
go through ramsey plus for a year i'm
gonna pay for it
which puts you into financial peace
university and puts you into every
dollar premium
and shows you how to handle money
because somebody needs to give you a hug
right now and that's me and ken
okay thank you so much i appreciate it
and i appreciate this advice i've been
one day debating one option one day
debating the other and i'm just
trying to figure out long term what
would be the best well the problem is
none of these options are
wonderful because of a less than
wonderful situation
yeah and so it's it's not good but
you're going to get through it and we're
going to show you how we'll walk with
you kiddo
i'm sorry that puts this hour the ramsay
show
in the books
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life your money and
with ken here especially your career
yeah looking for jobs uh thinking about
telling the boss to take this job and
well ken can help
you yeah and uh little johnny paycheck
reference there
just gotta brought that in there it
looks like that that's a good night what
a great song
yeah it's a classic bunch of young
people need you to finish that line the
song is take this job and shove it yeah
and we're trying to help you do that
don't jump yeah don't jump absolutely
find the right job
keep paying off debt you don't have to
go backwards in your debt snowball you
can actually pursue work you've always
wanted to do
and not stop the baby steps there you go
we get that question
a lot which is a it's a natural question
i'll tell you how
phone number triple eight eight two five
five
two two five johnny is with us in san
antonio hi johnny how are you
hey doing great guys how are you doing
better than we deserve what's up brother
great thanks for taking my call
so i'm uh in my mid to late 60s
and i'm thinking about retiring soon and
i want to know i've got some money to
save in savings
and i wanted to know if it's better to
put it towards the mortgage
or do some kind of investments ira
or and if you have an elp in san antonio
you would recommend
my income is 75 annual
my wife's social security is about 850 a
month
um we have investments of
uh we have a fixed annuity of around 40
k
and then ira my wife has an ira of 16k
so that's a total of 56.
cool mortgage is 238 uh
on a 2.75 30-year fix and we're four
years into it
good for you well as you probably have
heard if you listen for more than about
three minutes we talk about the baby
steps all the time which is the clear
path to wealth
and uh the idea being we're out of debt
so you're out of debt everything but
your house right
right cars are paid for and the house is
the only thing and you have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses in place your rainy day fund
right
correct good yeah and in savings right
now i've got 33k
and i'm getting another 5 000 bonus good
uh
we do have 5k allocated for a new range
that we need to replace that's the only
major your next goal
is continue putting 15 of your household
income into retirement
and to continue to build your nest egg
and let's get this house paid off that's
baby steps four
and six and so lean into that house and
let's get that thing finished off how
much
you said you got oh 200 and some money
right yeah 230
hey yeah so let's uh and that becomes a
big goal because if by the time you quit
work if you have a really nice nest egg
and a paid for house you have a very
stable
situation if when you retire yourself a
home mortgage it's
destabilizing it's less than stable
because you've got that stinking payment
laying there staring at you
and um uh it changes the last 30 years
of your life to live in a paid for house
dramatically
so well done you're on your way tamron
is in new york city
hey tamron welcome to the ramsey show
thank you so much for having me how are
you doing today
better than i deserve how can we help
i am calling i recently i have a
question
that relates to college and when um
it is okay or sensible to
derail the plan and borrow for college
my husband and i we actually didn't even
discover
your system until during the pandemic
and we've paid down a lot of debt we've
sold a rental property
um set up our emergency fund wonderful
progress in one year well selling the
selling the rental property
gave us a large sum and we're blessed to
have terrific
careers but my
oldest son is a senior in high school
this year and
last year he expressed an interest that
his dream school was
a prestigious private university that's
around here i
graduated law school from there myself
so um
tugged at my heart and i was supportive
of him that if he
did everything that was necessary and
got the grades
and kept everything up as long as he
could get scholarships and aid and the
out-of-pocket expenses
for us with less than 25 000 a year that
we could afford to pay
cash through the school's payment plan
and that
he could go there my sophomore
however he had some trouble
when he started high school last year
and he was getting into trouble
and he was making poor decisions and
then when they closed the schools down
he
kind of continued to go down
a scary path from our perspective and he
asked us if he could go away
to a boarding school to a military
school
that's not too far from where we live
and
seeing that that was best for him we
immediately in december
agreed and enrolled him and sent him but
i'm now paying
2500 a month for him to go to school
and our budget only has
after all of the um bills and essentials
um like food and you know clothing
allows and haircuts like really the full
budget
only has about four thousand dollars to
spare in it
what's your household in i don't know um
right now we're at about 240
and i will be wrapping up my clerkship
my post law school clerkship
so i would expect that next year
it'll be um closer to 300 if not over
300 which will give you the money to
send the other one mm-hmm
yeah and that's why i was there's not a
plan where i do
we've been going back and forth to
answer your earlier question there's not
a plan where i put you into student
loans
okay there's two options here one is we
figure this out or junior picks a
different school
okay and his future is not ruined based
on that
in pause listen pause is doesn't mean
never it doesn't mean stop it's he could
do his first year somewhere else in
three years three through four yeah uh
or two through four
at the at the uh dream prestige school
again if he lines up
all the scholarships and it's 25 000 out
of pocket with no
student loans he can also work towards
this
you know i mean he understands what's
going on in the family and assuming you
guys are
there's some harmony there and he's as
healthy as an 18 17
year old can be about his brother's
situation he can work and kind of help
out
you know with this process as well and
say hey here's where i think this is a
family meeting i think you sit him down
he says
he knows what's going on and just say
hey here's where we are
this is reality student loans is not an
option we're not going to do that
that's what dad and i have been doing
you've seen us getting out of debt
bring him in the bigger picture and say
hey life happens sometimes
this is a you know it's not fair that's
right it's sad and you didn't do
anything wrong
uh and yet it's affecting you but still
it is affecting you and so here's what
we're gonna
do uh let's pretend that you're you lost
your job and you you couldn't send him
to that school
you'd have the same conversation and it
wouldn't be his fault
you know you would have lost your job
and he would have to deal with that
kids kids can deal with this so hold on
we're going to send you a copy anthony's
book debt-free degree i want you all to
read that as a family
and i want you to commit to working some
kind of a cash flow game plan
to some school that you pay cash for
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Music]
i know what it feels like to think
you're never going to be able to save
money
[Applause]
i know what it feels like to think
you're never going to get out of that
but you can actually do it and we can
show you how
it's what we do inside of ramsey plus
ramsey plus is our step-by-step plan
that gets you quick wins
so you can make faster progress on your
debt and once that debt's gone for good
you get more money back in your pocket
the best part is you can try it for free
once you become a member you'll also get
benefits like the
federal classic e-file with ramsey smart
tax free included the audio book of
rachel cruz's brand new best seller know
yourself know your money
free included and of course financial
peace university and of course every
dollar premium version
and of course you're gonna finally get
your money under control and we're going
to show you exactly
how to do that you can try it for free
but
before before becoming a member just go
to daveramsey.com
ramseyplus and check out the free trial
daveramsey.com ramsey plus riverside
california is on the line
ken is calling hi ken how are you
hey hi dave hi ken thanks for taking my
call
sure how can we help so it's going to
start off sounding like a sob story it's
going to turn out with a good ending
right well
i've actually become debt free
went through a disability thing with
with a failed back surgery
turning 53 next week but dave i've done
fpu coordinating multiple times i'm just
here to tell you
as everybody does that your principles
work the baby steps work and if i can do
it anybody can
when i went from being you know high on
the hog owning a
successful business to disabled i lost a
lot
but i didn't lose hope and i kept
plugging away i kept
you know doing the fpu coordinating even
after all that
and dave i've counseled people i've
helped people out
the principles work obviously i enjoy
helping people here's my question i
won't ramble on too long
i'm looking at the coaching program
i've always done financial coaching as a
ministry though i've never charged for
it and turning 53 next week i'm getting
up there
i am disabled my income is only just
under 2 000 a month here in california
which being debt-free
mortgage and everything is a good thing
i'm just wondering with ken there
you know with a career and everything
else is it a good idea for someone in my
situation
to save up might take me six months to a
year to do it
to get that certification to do it as a
ministry
well uh ministry or would you charge for
it when you say ministry what does that
mean i've never
charged i've always just done the
financial coaching for free it's just
something that i've enjoyed giving back
doing
i really feel like with my story it's
very relatable a lot of people feel like
wow
anybody can and stay positive you know
yeah
well look when somebody asks me is this
a good career move i walk them through
the sweet spot analogy which is very
simple
our creator gave people talent things
you do well and you're supposed to use
those as tools to do work that you love
that fires you up when you think about
it when you do it and then
allows you to accomplish to produce
results that
mean something to you uh we know that
this means something to you so the
question is if i talk to everybody that
knows you can will they say that you're
a good communicator
yes yes people are calling me all the
time i know i'm helping people in my
family right now that's right and you're
good at instruction which is what it
takes to be a good coach communication
and you got to be good at communication
you got to be good at instruction you
got to have a heart for people you have
all three of those so the answer is
yeah this is a good move i i would just
challenge you i have no problem with you
doing it uh
pro bono or as a ministry
but i just sit here and look at your
situation and i think you could
because there's no financial pressure on
you to make money as a financial coach
that's a good
thing because this takes time to build
this this is a
one-to-one we build one client at a time
um i just wonder why you wouldn't
eventually charge because our our team
can not only
uh train you how to be a really great
coach but how to build your business are
you opposed to it
no no i just never have i i've done
hundreds of
appointments you know and i i think
you're i think you're going to do
some of both if i'm you uh-huh yeah i
think you're going to start charging for
some
and then occasionally you're going to
see someone you just need to help and
you just want to do that
and you just want to give them a leg up
and you want to get them started but the
the ramsey preferred coaches who have
gone through all of the training
and then that we send leads to some of
them are making pretty substantial
incomes
the top ones are and so let's just
pretend let's just say you made 100 000
a year doing this for fun uh then you
could also give away a bunch of your
services as well right
sure sure yeah there's no reason you
can't do both so
here's what we're going to do i'm going
to pay for it i want you to go through
the door that's great
you need to go through the training oh
my gosh seriously you've earned it
you you're the man i mean you got listen
having a testimony is a wonderful thing
getting one's a pain in the butt the
truth and you have been through that's
the truth and so
yeah i want you to go through the
training and some i don't usually give
away it's a pretty expensive item but
uh madison pickup and we'll get him
through the first series of courses i
you can talk to the coaching team and
figure out what what the proper way to
get him started on this is uh
and uh just tell them i said this is
this one's a gift on me
that's so cool you know see i kind of
you know what you see what i just did
there
it's what i told him to do yeah go make
a bunch of money yep
and give some away give some of it away
yeah because he's going to be in a
situation where he can uh
he can do financial coaching for
somebody who maybe he's going through
something he went through yeah
a physical injury that rocks your world
and i gotta tell you man
it's dad gum pain and
medical bills are uh we see them in our
counseling office our coaching offices
every day all across america
it's a it's a real real thing without a
doubt
gene is with us in colorado springs hi
gene welcome to the ramsay show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
without going into all the glory details
my husband and i have separate accounts
we just put the house in both our names
i have no debt
he already had a home equity loan on the
house
plus a car loan now he wants to borrow
more money to buy some firearms
and with the housing in both our names
it's
joint tenants not survivorship i would
have to find
some papers to say i could
consent to him getting a lien on the
house
should i do it to buy guns
yes how old are you guys i'm 68 and he's
76.
and how long have you been married over
15 years
okay i have a huge gun collection i'm a
gun guy i can't possibly imagine
borrowing on my house to buy a freaking
gun
i'm a gun guy i'm your husband okay i
would i would be on his side but i can't
possibly imagine what
what gun purchase there could be that
justifies
borrowing on your personal home to buy
it
what is he buying a tank no
they're um single shot high wall
wall whatever um and he
went to us he went to a gun shop and
they had these great deals and he knows
he could get
a lot of money off selling them
yeah he doesn't need to get in the
firearms business at 76 years old by
borrowing on his home
no i i don't think this is a good plan
and if he called me i would tell him not
to do it and so i'm going to tell you
not to
allow your home to be done because when
this all goes out sideways and he can't
sell these guns
uh for whatever reason as an individual
or a collector or whatever he's getting
into here i can't tell what the flip
he's getting into
but uh it must be a very expensive
collectible gun of some kind of sound
sounds like he got a great deal he
thinks oh i can buy this now hold on
from a gun shop
he's going to steal it from a gun shop
yeah like they're going to give him a
deal so he can make a lot on it i got
questions
yeah i'm thinking ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding warning warning
warning
because that's what retailers are known
for dave yeah they're known for giving
things away at cheap so you can make
more money on it later
yeah gun shops are known for not having
no idea the value of the guns in their
shops
we're being sarcastic your husband's
plan
sucks don't get into debt to do it
and that's from a couple of gun guys oh
my gosh
wow can't believe i told somebody not
buy a gun i know just happened right
here
yeah that's harder than telling them not
by boat
wow this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more always use the
magic word
the promo code ramsay
today's question comes from amy nebraska
she writes in i have a job interview
coming up for an entry level position as
an assistant manager
for a coffee chain if salary is not
brought up by my interviewer
when is the best time for me to ask
about it uh you ask about it when they
offer you the job
because presumably not always but
presumably
when they offer you the job amy they're
going to tell you
what they are offering the job at as an
hourly rate and at that point
then you can discuss that but i would
not ask about it early on i always tell
people dave in the interview process
you want to convince that hiring manager
that you will help them win
we've got to remember that they're
people too and they're looking for
somebody that's going to help them
win and so there will come a time in
this particular question
where uh the uh the hourly rate the
salary whatever that is is going to come
up
completely through the interview and
you're walking out of your first
interview and you still have
no idea what the pay is you don't ask
well
fair question but in this situation um
you can you have a good idea what an
hourly rate is going to be at a coffee
shop you have a pretty good idea and you
can find that out
uh pretty easily you have a ballpark
range i mean
it's not going to be something like
seven eight nine dollars an hour you're
probably going to be in that
low range would be 10 with the minimum
wage politicizing that's going on right
now you're probably going to be in that
12 to 15
an hour so you shouldn't walk into an
interview like that going
i have no idea what i can and can't do
so it's a good point to bring up but you
have
to have an eye an eye on the type of
work and do your homework prior to the
job that's what i teach
you can find out what people are paying
you can find out if it's a good coffee
shop to work at before you ever show up
so i agree with the general sentiment
that you would not
uh if someone i teach our guys here in
recruiting
if they lead with what do you pay what
are the benefits
just end the interview yeah totally
agree because they're here for what they
can take not what they can give yeah
and so it's over yeah and so that's the
other end of that sentiment right
uh uh but i i would be perfectly
careful at the end of the interview if
nothing has been brought up
to start with that's a really sucky
interviewer
that does not cover some of what's going
on that is your interview that's
true but uh if that's the case uh
you get to the end of it and just go hey
i really appreciate our time our
conversation
i think i can add value here if this
were to work out what is the
general yeah i'm playing with that i'm
fine with that what's the range i'm fine
with it or something like that yes just
so i kind of
so i kind of know what to anticipate and
then you can go
that because that you may want to rule
them out yes
you may not want to go through three
interviews and get hired for
half of what you think you're going to
get well you're not going to go through
three interviews for an hourly wage like
this
that is good context that i agree with
my point is this
when you're going for an entry level
position you need to have already done
your homework on that place
do they treat people like they're just
robots and soulless people and they're
just moving burn and churn through this
do some homework find out is this a
great place to work you can do that very
easily
it's not difficult with all the
resources we have in this world so
with that being the context i'm always
wanting people to show up at that
interview
and and absolutely blow them away so
that they go
they want you and the time comes then
you could
practice for a real job it is because
you're not going to bring up salary
you're not going to bring that up in the
first now you better not i mean it's bad
i mean i had a young guy i'll never
forget one of the way
back i mean we had 10 people and we had
this young guy i ran into him i was
speaking to church he came up he was
real enthusiastic afterwards i was
talking to him for 20 minutes
and i said you know he said are you
hiring for anything i said yeah
yeah and he came over and he sat down
it was so disappointing because he was
such a rock star in
so many ways but the first thing out of
his mouth is okay what's this pay
yeah and what are your benefits
packaging it makes me cringe hearing
it's because because he you know he
instantly revealed his heart
yes which is i'm here to take rather
than to add
yes and i can't come into the business i
own
with that attitude yeah i'm here what
can i take versus what can i add
you better put some water in the bucket
or there'll be no water in the bucket
and remember for entry level jobs you're
up against a lot of people
it's a factory so i want you to put your
best foot forward i'm not
i like what you said i'd be okay with
that but i want you to win the position
when their trust and confidence when
they offer it then you say
you're probably going to do that in that
first interview yeah
because to your point to your point
they're not going to do six interviews
like we did and they're shuffling people
through
yeah and uh so you want to be classy did
you fog up the mirror okay yeah
well in some places that's the case yeah
if yeah you can get hired
smile pass the drug test and fog up a
mirror yes
you don't even have to smile i can prove
that by some of the people that serve
coffee so i'm just telling you
bad experience dave i won't bring up a
brand new
dart sierra in orlando
hey sierra how are you i'm well good
afternoon how are you guys
better than we deserve how can we
i have a question about taxes
this is the first year that i will be
doing mostly contract work
i worked as a pa a physician assistant
and i reached out to i think two elps
or three and i got kind of three
different answers and i'm just confused
um one of them recommended that i
open an llc no and then pay myself
no okay i didn't like it
the other one said yes open the llc
pay your own payroll company no but
they're wanting money monthly
and the third said just pay 25
every three months to the irs ding ding
ding there's your answer that's the one
you want
okay yeah you what i would tell you to
do is just
open a separate checking account in your
social security number it's a dba
doing business ads and you have a little
separate business account and you put
all of your income
into that business account when you want
to pull money out of that and take it
home to buy things at home or pay bills
at home or pay debt at home or whatever
you'd hold back 25 over into a separate
savings account to pay your quarterly
estimates annual problem unless you make
over a hundred thousand dollars a year
25
will cover it yes it's probably between
8 to 10 grand a month
um unfortunately there is an llc now
open
that's okay it's not the other world if
you want to run it through that now that
you did it that's okay
because it'll have its own ein number
and you just run it through that you can
but it serves exactly the same purpose
you just added
the paperwork and the expense of the llc
to the process and now you've also added
a new tax return to the process because
you get to file a tax return on the llc
so you get to file a tax return plus the
llc file files one so you've
i want to ask you about that day for her
shouldn't you just shut that down then
why go through all those extra steps i
mean i know she opened it she paid money
probably for somebody else
you know it's just not that big it's not
worth it it's just
it's a hassle because you got one extra
tax return yeah but
um yeah you know you're going to have a
schedule c
on your uh personal return if you don't
do the llc
so you've got some forms to fill out
anyway so for taxes so
you know uh it's not the end of the
world to do that i definitely would not
use a payroll company to pay yourself
that's nightmarish uh but uh
i i don't recommend solopreneurs unless
they have
lots of money an llc is not there for
tax purposes it's there for
risk management it's there for if that
company gets sued
you don't want to be the individual that
owns it uh so as an example
i actually own absolutely nothing now
i don't own a thing it's all in llc's
in corporations in trusts um
and uh all of my real estate is uh my
cars are even in an llc so if there's a
car wreck
you can sue the company that owns the
cars because that's who owns them
i don't know and so you know the
liability it's a
risk management tool is all it is it's
to get the risk
down it is not to get taxes off of you
so
i don't use llc's for tax purposes they
don't really serve one
in her situation get educated on all
those write-offs of being a 1099 or
contractor yeah you'd be surprised how
much you can write off now that you're
good your tax elp would be great for
absolutely this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture of the day romans 8 18 for
i consider that the sufferings of this
present time are not worth comparing
with the glory that is to be revealed to
us
robert hughes said the struggle you're
in today is developing the strength you
need tomorrow
well that's the truth brandon's with us
in salt lake city hi
brandon how are you hi i'm doing great
how about you guys better than we
deserve how can we help
wow it's a pleasure to be talking to you
both i'm very thankful for the
opportunity you guys are at uh
to help me out i'm uh i'm currently in
the job application process i'm a senior
in college and um i'm currently
i so i've applied to a position that i
really really
would like for a large corporation but
the one problem is i'm trying to be
proactive and
trying to contact the or anyone a
recruiter just to say hey this is my job
application
trying to stand out from all these from
all these candidates
but i can't find a recruiter because
there's
there's hundreds of them in this company
um i do
have a contact for i'm actually
connected with the person
i'd be applying for on linkedin right
but i i'm i don't know if it would be
wrong for me just to jump the whole
recruitment process oh yeah and contact
them directly
oh yeah but ken's going to tell you how
to do that yeah
yeah yeah well what do you what are you
worried about if you reach out to them
directly you're going to get like
they're going to black ball is that what
you're talking about
yeah kind of like oh this is annoying
he's just he's not following the
uh and you've already applied you've
already applied
correct that's correct i applied about a
week ago yes yeah
well it's a major company so they've got
a big big system and they've got a
process so
you know one way you could go about this
that i think would not get you in hot
water
you've got the person who's hiring
linkedin information
so you're pretty resourceful young man i
do a handwritten note
just something simple hey just want to
let you know i've applied recently
and love the company if i ever get the
opportunity to work here here's why i'd
want to work here really short
sweet yeah let me give you another line
to enter into that okay yeah go ahead
and just in that note go hey and there's
a fine line between showing initiative
and being just weird i want to be right
near that line
he acknowledged that you've done some
homework yeah but i'm okay with that
because a handwritten note is not creepy
no you find their email and they're
wondering how in the world you get that
but if i read that and i'm the executive
on the other side i'm gonna go that's
funny
yes i like this i love that dave that's
a great suggestion it's very very good
i think the handwritten note is the way
i would go but now what i would really
work on is through all of your contacts
yeah here we go here
this is the proximity principle and
we're looking at your web of connections
we know from sociology research
that the number one way to get jobs is
through
acquaintances so get outside of your
family and friends that's that close
personal network picture spiderweb
we're gonna go out okay so now we're
looking at everybody we know on social
media
how many people you think they know so
let's just i'm using this example let's
say you got 500 friends on facebook
well how many friends do each of those
500 500 have
and you've got to get aggressive there
and just ask for people to help you
don't be weird does anybody
know anybody that works at x boom i'm
applying i've already applied a company
xyz do you know anybody that works there
and let's see what that yields and then
i would go to the personal context
outside of social media same deal reach
out to everybody you know hey
i just want a shot at an interview
that's not asking too much
that's not creepy that's not arrogant
that shows
desire and you'd be surprised what that
will yield but you got to really work
hard
um and and and then let the chips fall
where they fall
on the official submission because
you're going to go through the system
i'd have you look at the ken coleman
resume guide uh we've got
six templates in addition to the free
one at the resume guide
uh at my website kencoleman.com check
that out submit the resume that way you
know
stand out let's just give it to him it's
it doesn't mean yeah that's free
madison oh my that wasn't six templates
give him the six templates yeah give him
the six templates free
and use those to reach in yeah and uh
then
and he's also if you'll read the stuff
at the downloads that are free at
kingcoleman.com
yeah it'll show you how to build the
letter to getting contact now i'll add
one other thing to ken's system which
can systems flawless but it's almost an
old sales technique i used to use
if you do get an actual interview
during the interview ask
when you should follow up and set an
appointment
for the follow-up love that that way
you're not
pestering it that way you're just
following through on what you said they
said well you know we'll know in a
couple of weeks would it be okay if i
contacted you
on friday the 14th and they will say yes
and then when you call on friday the
14th they go yes they brandon said he
was going to call
he called that's a good sign for him but
also then you're not trying to chase
somebody in phone tag
or you're not trying to you know you're
not worried that you're pestering them
on a follow-up
yeah because the follow-up is set you
schedule
your follow-up and then it's not
pestering it's expected
and then let it go i mean one of the
worst things you can do is just keep
emailing somebody look if they want you
trust me
they're gonna get back to you do a great
job do your best job in the interview do
a follow-up we have a touch point
timeline free guy
get six other places to go after a while
you're going after this that's right
don't sit around and wait
good idea yeah yeah so hold on
madison will pick up and she'll get you
those templates and a copy of ken's book
the proximity principle
we're going to set you up man for going
to get the job you want and listen i
need you to call ken coleman on his show
uh and let him know if you get this job
using these techniques
i want to hear the story yeah we get a
lot of fun emails this stuff really does
work
and here's the other thing you know if
it doesn't work let's let's let's really
figure out how
to open up our connections because what
people don't know dave is
is that they know everybody they already
need to know i know that seems
intimidating one degree of separation
it really is yeah it's when i was a kid
we played this thing called the match
game uh you got grandkids now yeah
but they still have the match we played
with our kids oh good and and so it's
this idea of what you just start turning
over the tiles and we go okay i saw an
elephant here i'm looking for another
elephant
that's the it's the simplicity of i've
got to be diligent
i know everybody i need to know i got to
keep talking about it i got to keep
asking people will help if we ask the
right way
yeah that's exactly right and
don't folks that are out there okay
there's a lot of people looking for jobs
and ken can coach you on this
you can get all the details you need
ramsey solutions will hire 340 people
this year if we meet our hiring goals
however we will have 25 000
applications come in if you simply fill
out an application and that's all you
ever do
there is a high probability that we will
have missed out
on hiring you it's true might as well
play the lottery while you're doing that
it's really a long shot in today's world
with so many people applying for so this
thing of i filled out
a hundred thousand applications on
monster.com and not one call me back
well no crap
not a one did you know our i used
ziprecruiter and did all these multiple
filings at one time and zipper crew is
great we advertise for them
yeah but but you cannot just
mass you know just throw enough mud
against the wall to see if something
sticks you've got to find that singular
connective spot
with someone that knows someone that
knows someone inside
and uh you know joe's friend works over
there and joe's friend's name's
sally and sally is going to get you know
at least
have a connectivity point well here's
another thing i got an email at the last
break
that a friend of mine had sent a lady
who wants to work here
right and sent her and i send them over
to hr sure
and that doesn't mean she's gonna get
hired but she's not in the stack anymore
oh no
she's at the top she's the top of the
pocket well she she may be at the top of
the wrong pile
right you know but she's in well she's
getting it look she's not gonna she's
getting a look
that's the issue there's gonna be a real
consideration chances go up when we get
interviews
yeah we're trying to get an interview
one thing we get all the time uh on the
on the ken coleman show dave is people
say okay ken i did what you said i
really truly don't
have a connection to somebody in the
company and so
the next best thing is with the the
resume guide and the resume templates at
kencombe.com we have flipped our resume
and the
hrc could you send that to that guy
online
but here's what you yeah absolutely you
can reach out but what we've done
in our resume and our hr team has worked
with me on this we've got a world-class
hr team at ramsey solutions
the top of our resume dave says who i
know so if you don't have a connection
to somebody
in the company let's use ramsey
solutions example then maybe you should
get a great endorsement from somebody
who uh is a world-class uh financial
advisor
smart investor pro who we may not know
personally but they're in our network or
if you're going into technology get a
great reference from somebody who's a
big shot in that field
it'll make them go huh yep they look at
you
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
[Music]
you